au revoir
elle m'envoie répit à samedi un ou à les
revoir
non
le soir
dondra
avant
j'en rêvais
comment
un truc et serge desaunay jeunes
musiciens et luthier originaire
d'argenteuil près de paris décidèrent un
jour de quitter le brouhaha de la ville
pour s'installer à ville rage aux petits
villages de la commune de blond aux
environs de l'image et de goûter ainsi
une autre façon de vous
e
deux ans
alam
ayez
passionné de musique traditionnelle ils
ont su rester entier préférant vivre
leur musique sans chercher à jouer les
paysans c'est peut-être cette sincérité
qui a conduit les habitants de blueant
les accepter et à les considérer comme
des villageois part entière on est venu
faire de la musique il ya deux ans ici
puis on a rencontré des les gens qui
sont devenus des copains
et puis on les a revus de plus en plus
souvent on est descendu et puis on a
fini par s'installer définitivement ici
on n'était pas chez nous à paris alors
déjà unique où il faut on avait besoin
de places pour l'atelier pour tout ça et
puis la campagne on aime bien et puis
maintenant je crois qu'il ya d'autres
aussi qui ont trouvé c'était très bien
comment être plus deux frères des zones
m il ya du copain elle qu'avec tous
maintenant a grandi un peu en famille
ben oui puisqu'on joue ensemble on fait
la musique ensemble alors c'est plus
pratique de d'être d'être toujours
ensemble ce qui lui étaient où avant
dans la halle ronde vous ouvriez
ensemble c'était oui on joue ensemble
savez quand on est à 600 kilomètres les
uns des autres ça posait certains
problèmes s'étaient pas pratique on
raccourcit les distances
vous êtes arrivé ici avec bausch lomb
vos instruments de musique bizarre votre
musique plus ou moins bizarre aussi ça
s'est passé facilement
ouais ça s'est passé bien déjà la
musique c'est pas la musique bizarre
c'est quand même la musique qu'ils
avaient entendu ici hein
alors on nous a parlé d'heure de gens
qui jouent à l'accordéon diatonique la
clarinette à côté
le lien ici quand les médias fait par la
musique une fois qu'ils ont vu poser la
musique il en
ils ont regardé ils sont à présent coûté
ils sont seize concerts retrouvez moi de
saluer notre manière de vivre ses
attachantes et je crois que ce qu'il est
ce qui les choque le plus c'est quand on
touche à tron 3 4 heures du mans mais
aussi ils ont vu que des fois on se
couche à trois quatre heures puis
c'était pour travailler alors au 6
septembre
non
quelle impression ça fait quand ils sont
arrivés devant les impressions
alaric avec leurs cheveux longs et leur
allure et de voir qu'il ne voulait pas
travailler
je ne parle pas ici mais et je bats
musique quotidiennement c'est pas mieux
vaut s'en va vous ne devez pas les dvg
ci est celle d'une rien fait de bon
on
et ça vous a surpris nous vous avez
trouvé ça normal de voir des seins en
jeunes arriver ça fait seulement ça m'a
surpris je pensais pas qu'ils fassent le
boulot qu'ils font
ah bon alors non ça je ne pensais pas ça
et vous trouvez ça bien vous aimez ça
ces prix simi les volets pourquoi pas ce
qu'ils disent et c'est pas la marche en
compagnie ça me va
m
mais il y avait une fille avec un petit
somme nulle dans une jeune fille qui
était bien ma foi mais elle est reparti
en partie d'un nord et la jeune fille
restée elle y rester et pieds de
parvenir ils sont revenus avec une autre
salle est bien de changement j'aime la
musique j'ai été trés j'aimais beaucoup
la musique mais ce que j'ai aimé c'est
elle la musique de l'accordéon et le
conte le musée ça hors du musée et moi
et je vous l'accordé mais oui oui mais
je ne critique pas c'est pas de
l'accordéon comme vous et maintenant gm
divers frais indus et
en fait notre musique c'est celle qui
ressemblent plus à des dessins d'enfants
c'est à dire tu ne sais rien tu as
oublié par le crayon de couleur tard
violon ou lie de vin créant de hull 3 tu
as une mandoline vous fait d'avoir une
belle créé en couleurs rouge et bleu tu
as mandole avec ça tu ne sais rien du
tout de ce que ça peut être le dessin tu
ne sais rien parce que ça peut être la
musique et tu racontes pas une ce que tu
as envie de raconter
bon si tu me prends au sérieux une
simple image de la musique qu'on a envie
de jouer
ce qui veut rien dire pour n'a pas envie
qu'elle se rebelle comme des enfants ils
ont envie camp des saints sont bons en
fait toutes les chansons on chante c'est
vrai ça tourne autour des thèmes de
l'amour la guerre
le travail étant donné que le travail
qui est fait actuellement il nous
intéresse pas tellement on ne sort pas
beaucoup de chansons de travail il vous
fait aussi des instruments ouais c'est
bien quand tu vu d'un instrument de
l'avoir fait déjà soi même c'est donc en
complet lire de plus vous montez le
saviez pas détourné de musique tout le
temps alors quand on n'est pas en soi
une musique motionnaire une semaine de
libre on n'a pas le changement de nom la
pole car vraiment de s'y remettre
et si on reste à la maison on a envie de
faire quelque chose pour le public s'est
trouvé des bois des correspondants si
vous trouvez des bois bien spécifique
cet égard le noyer l'érable le platane
mouchetés la cage ou non mais c'est tout
des boucs ont trouvé encore relativement
facilement mais je les trouvais très
droite fil 100 me et surtout très sec
à
ça faisait deux ans qu'il n'y avait pas
eu deux n'y avait pas eu de feu ça gens
là et puis passer avec le comité des
fêtes en appel on avait parlé et puis ça
s'est bien passé
si vous faites partie du comité des
fêtes ouais il n'était pas si ça c'est
une loi s'est bien passé les gens
étaient contents de recommencer à faire
là ce qui faisait dans le temps quoi
jeter à l'usiné puis je me prendrais
quand même
pendant que j'allais là quand c'est à
dire du premier round 31 août j'avais
droit à des vacances
quand j'étais vachement content tu vois
je partais sont là avec mon petit camion
d'un petit photo je partais en vacances
et puis un jour jean pour près des gens
qui faisaient une musique estimant
qu'ils m'ont surtout en dehors de donner
l'espoir que je pouvais faire autre
chose tu vois que tu vois ce que je veux
dire là quand je parle d'espoir c'est
mon pas donner simplement l'idée m'ont
redonné l'espoir l'espoir de pouvoir
vivre autre chose que ce qu'on puisse
qu'on fait durant tous les jours dans un
certain francis thème j'aime bien ce mot
dans une certaine société
là
m
elle
oui
m
il fera des zonas c'est quelque chose
que j'ai pu rencontrer encore à vendre
c'est des gens qui font de la musique
sans franchi 12h et 14h et qui savent
comme ce qu'il veut le faire c'est des
gens où on arrive à bien se brancher un
simple parce qu'il ya on ne fait pas de
la musique on la vit ou en plus on est
là deux mois chez nous on est des mots
chez eux ils sont des mots chez nous et
puis on taille notre bois on fait notre
bouchons ont fait une nouvelle sur ça on
va travailler tant en parle ensemble
pour avoir de l'argent pour manger
si on fait de la musique quand ça vient
comme ça vient
la famille
pour la palme
et